[Music]
now it's the holiday season
and it got us thinking this is a great
excuse to bring back the super slow-mo
camera to help us celebrate this very
special that's what we did
take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was beautiful looking I did not
anticipate though getting both nostrils
full of eggnog that was unpleasant
yeah look at this you can see keep going
your whole body was filled with eggnog I
had my eyes closed but I knew like oh
that was a good one yeah yeah by the way
not all of our holidays super slo-mo
shots went that smoothly in the interest
of full disclosure we're gonna show you
an outtake right now okay now the plan
was for me to get a slo-mo kiss from a
dog under some mistletoe and see his
tongue going up all around me and that
would look really cute and fun
unfortunately they went out and they got
a dog that weighs 180 pounds and is
hyperactive
and it was rough take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't even see cuz he punches he
punched me in this side of the face
hardened and I was stunned it's the
strongest dog I've ever encountered in
my life he punched me and starts clawing
me and before I know it he's having sex
with me and then and then just as it's
getting good the trainer comes in
he was just gonna skip the kiss and get
right